STAY HERE.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker:
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME
TO "TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
HERE IS BREAKING NEWS WE NEVER
EXPECTED TO REPORT.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS NOW MORE
POPULAR THAN THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES AND OUT
SLIGHTLY MORE POPULAR THAN THE
PRESIDENT, MUCH MORE POPULAR.
A SURVEY THIS WEEK AND RIGHT
WINNING POSTER FOUND 62% OF
LIKELY VOTERS NOW HAVE A
FAVORABLE OPINION OF BLACK
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" AND
DONALD TRUMP’S APPROVAL RATING
43%.
ALMOST 20 POINTS LOWER.
BY THE WAY, TRUMP WAS NOT ALONE.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS MORE
POPULAR THAN JOE BIDEN HAS TOO.
IT’S MORE POPULAR THAN AMERICANS
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTION FROM ALL
OF THEM.
IT IS MORE POPULAR THAN THE
MEDIA, CONGRESS AND BIG
BUSINESS.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS MORE
POPULAR BY DOUBLE DIGITS THAN
BOTH THE DEMOCRATIC AND
REPUBLICAN PARTIES.
IT IS ALMOST AS POPULAR AS THE
U.S. MILITARY.
IT IS MUCH MORE POPULAR THAN THE
POPE.
THE NUMBERS ARE ASTOUNDING, BUT
THE POLLS ARE NOT THE ONLY
MEASURE OF IT.
HERE IS A "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
RALLY OVER THE WEEKEND IN
NEW YORK.
LOOK AT THAT PICTURE PARENT THAT
IS AN OCEAN OF PEOPLE.
ASK YOURSELF THE LAST TIME YOU
SAW A CANDIDATE FOR OFFICE TO
DRAW A CROWD LIKE THAT.
THE MEDIA RELENTLESSLY WITH
COVERAGE DESCRIBE
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" AS AN
ACTIVIST GROUP OR PROTEST
MOVEMENT.
BY THAT IS DECEPTION BY AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS NOT A
COLLECTION OF MARCHERS OR
SCIENCE OR A CONVENTIONAL
POLITICAL LOBBYIST PLANNED
PARENTHOOD WITH THE NRA.
IT IS NOT PRESSURING CONGRESS
WITH A NEW SET OF LAWS.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS FAR MORE
AMBITIOUS THAN THAT.
IT IS WORKING TO REMAKE THE
COUNTRY AND THEN TO CONTROL IT.
IT IS A POLITICAL PARTY.
AS OF TONIGHT,
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" MAY BE THE
MOST SINGLE POWERFUL PARTY IN
THE UNITED STATES.
NOBODY SAID THAT OUT LOUD BUT
POLITICIANS UNDERSTAND IT
PERFECTLY WELL.
IF NOTHING ELSE THEY UNDERSTAND
POWER BECAUSE I CAN SMELL IT AT
GREAT DISTANCE.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE LINING UP
TO BOW BEFORE
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
>> YOU CAN’T REALLY REFORM THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IS ROTTEN TO THE
ROOT.
>> WE HEARD OUR PEOPLE CRY OUT,
"I CAN’T BREATHE."
WE HEARD OUR PEOPLE STAND OUT
FROM A "BLACK LIVES MATTER."
THIS IS A SYSTEMIC PROBLEM THAT
REQUIRES A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION.
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THERE IS
A LEGITIMACY WITH ANGER.
AND OUTRAGE.
>> NONE OF WHAT YOU SAW IS A
STRETCH FOR DEMOCRATS.
THEY BELIEVE LONG-TERM GOALS
ALIGN WITH THOSE WITH
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" AND AT
TIMES THEY FUNCTION AS AN ARM OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
MORE TELLING AN OMINOUS IS THE
RESPONSE FROM MANY REPUBLICANS.
THEY’VE BEEN HAPPY TO GO ALONG
AS WELL OR MITT ROMNEY SMELLED
THE SAME SLOGANS.
>> VIOLENCE AND BRUTALITY AND
MAKE SURE THE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
THAT "BLACK LIVES MATTER."
>> Martha:>> Tucker: THAT WAS TH
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
IF EVER THERE WAS AN INDICATOR
HOW POWERFUL
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" HAS BECOME,
YOU JUST SAW IT, REPUBLICAN
LEADERS BRAG ABOUT THEIR STRONG
CONSERVATIVE CONVICTIONS BUT
MOSTLY THEY WANT TO BE ON THE
WINNING TEAM WHATEVER THAT IS.
THAT IS WHY THEY PAUSE BEFORE
OFFENDING CHINA.
WHEN "BLACK LIVES MATTER" SAYS
TAKE A KNEE, THEY DO.
IT IS ALL PRETTY STRANGE WHEN
YOU THINK ABOUT IT.
IF THE LEADERS OF
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" ARE
POLITICAL ACTORS, AND THEY ARE,
BY DEFINITION YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
HAVE ANY OPINION YOU WANT TO
HAVE ABOUT THEM.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" WANTS TO
RUN THE COUNTRY, THEREFORE, YOU
CAN CRITICIZE
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
THOSE ARE THE RULES OF THE
SYSTEM BUT NOT ANYMORE.
IMAGINE A WORLD WHERE YOU ARE
PUNISHED FOR QUESTIONING THE
BEHAVIOR OF THE PRESIDENT OR FOR
INSULTING YOUR LOCAL MAYOR.
YOU PROBABLY CAN’T IMAGINE THAT
BECAUSE IT’S TOO BIZARRE.
IT IS UN-AMERICAN THAT THAT IS
WHERE WE ARE RIGHT NOW.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" HAS CHANGE
THE RULES AND THIS IS THE FIRST
NEW RULE, NO CRITICIZING
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
YOU CAN BE FIRED FROM YOUR JOB
IF YOU DISOBEY.
MANY AMERICANS HAVE BEEN.
ON FRIDAY, FOR EXAMPLE THE
PRINCIPLE OF THE PUBLIC WAS
DISMISSED FROM HER JOB FOR
POSTING A FOLLOWING WORDS ON
FACEBOOK PAGE "I UNDERSTAND THE
URGENCY TO FEEL COMPELLED TO
ADVOCATE FOR BLACK LIVES, WHAT
ABOUT FELLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT?
JUST BECAUSE I DON’T WALK AROUND
WITH A BLM SIGN SHOULD NOT MEAN
I’M A RACIST."
UNFORTUNATELY THE PRINCIPAL’S
BOSS DISAGREED AND THE
SUPERINTENDENT OF WINDSOR
SCHOOLS DESCRIBE THE QUOTE YOU
JUST HEARD AS "OUTRIGHT RACIST."
BY THE WAY 97% WHITE.
ALSO ON FRIDAY IN THE ECONOMIST
LOST HIS JOB AT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE BANK IN CHICAGO
FOR DARING TO OFFER MILD
CRITICISM ON THAT.
ON TWITTER, "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
HAD "TORPEDOED ITSELF WITH
FULL-FLEDGED SUPPORTIVE HASHTAG
DEFINED THE POLICE.
NOW IS THE TIME FOR SENSIBLE
ADULTS TO ENTER BACK INTO THE
ROOM WITH SERIOUS EARNEST
RESPECTFUL CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
IT ALL.
THAT WAS A STATEMENT CONCLUDED
SO THEY FIRED HAROLD.
WE CAN GIVE YOU MANY OTHER
EXAMPLES OF THE SAME THING
HAPPENING.
AND "BLACK LIVES MATTER" NOW
ENJOYS COMPLETE IMMUNITY FROM
CRITICISM.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED FOR
AMERICAN POLITICAL MOVEMENT BUT
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS MORE
POWERFUL THAN THAT.
IT HAS NO HANDEDLY ADVISED THEIR
MORAL FRAMEWORK.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" DO MATTER,
THAT IS A STATEMENT OF FACT AND
NO DECENT PERSON DOUBTS THAT IS
TRUE BECAUSE IT IS.
IT IS TRUE PRECISELY BECAUSE
EVERY LIFE MATTERS.
WE ARE ALL HUMAN BEINGS AND
EVERYONE OF US.
WE HAVE SOULS, SKIN COLOR IS
IRRELEVANT TO MORAL VALUE.
UNTIL RECENTLY, THIS WAS
CONSIDERED OBVIOUS.
SAYING IT WAS REGARDED AS A
VIRTUE.
ALL LIVES MATTER TO EQUALLY AND
ALL CREATED BY GOD TO PURITY IN
THE END, ALL OF US WILL DIE AND
NOTHING CAN CHANGE THAT, NOT
WEALTH, NOT FAME, NOT RACE.
EVERY LIFE IS PRECISELY AS
VALUABLE AS EVERY OTHER LIFE.
BY THE WAY, THAT IDEA FORMS THE
BASIS OF THE CHRISTIAN FAITH.
IT IS THE ENTIRE PREMISE BEHIND
OUR FOUNDING DOCUMENTS.
AND YET, SUDDENLY, THANKS TO
"BLACK LIVES MATTER," YOU CAN NO
LONGER SAY IT OUT LOUD.
AFFIRMING THE FUNDAMENTAL
EQUALITY OF ALL PEOPLE IS NOW
CONSIDERED HATE SPEECH.
YOU CAN BE FIRED FOR SAYING IT.
AGAIN, MANY PEOPLE HAVE BEEN.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS MOMENT.
HOW DID WE GET HERE?
IN A WORD QUICKLY, IT HAPPENED
FAST.
AS RECENTLY AS DECEMBER BEFORE
THE RIOTS, MOST AMERICANS DID
NOT APPROVE OF
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
THE GROUP WAS DEFINED IN THE
PUBLIC MIND BY MOMENTS LIKE THIS
THIS.
[CHANTING]
>> Tucker: PIGS IN A BLANKET
FRY LIKE BACON.
KILL THE POLICE.
THEY YELLED THAT AT A RALLY.
THE USUAL LAYERS IMMEDIATELY
SCOOP AND TO PRETEND IT NEVER
HAPPENED.
THE PRESIDENT OF SOUTHERN
PROPERTY LAW CENTER WITH AN
OP-ED CONSIDERED NOT CONSIDERING
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" A HATE
GROUP.
BUT THE VIDEO WAS ONLINE.
A LOT OF FACTS ABOUT
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" STILL
RESIDE ON THE INTERNET.
THEY HAVE NOT BEEN SCRUBBED.
THE GROUP SIGNATURE DEMAND TO
ELIMINATE LAW ENFORCEMENT.
WHEN YOU FIRST HEARD PROTESTERS
SCREAM "DEFUND THE POLICE" IT
MAY HAVE TALKED TO YOU AND YOU
THOUGHT THAT WAS CRAZY.
AND LIMITING LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
RISING QUICKLY IN THE POLLS.
MINNEAPOLIS IS ALREADY DOING IT.
OTHER CITIES WILL FOLLOW.
ARE YOU SURPRISED?
ALMOST NO ONE IN PUBLIC LIFE HAS
PUSHED BACK MEANINGFULLY AGAINST
THE IDEA OF DEFINING THE POLICE.
THE "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
POSITION IS THE ONLY POSITION
MOST PEOPLE HERE.
AFTER A WHILE THEY BELIEVE IT,
AND CHALLENGE CLAIMS MUST BE
TRUE.
THAT IS WHAT MOST PEOPLE ASSUME
AND WHY WOULDN’T THEY ASSUME
THAT?
IF YOU DISAGREE, SAY SOMETHING
BUT OTHERWISE IT’S MUCH MORE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN.
SO WITH THAT IN MIND, CONSIDER
THE OTHER POSITIONS
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" HAS
ENDORSED THE REPEAL OF ALL
IMMIGRATION RESTRICTIONS FOR
STARTERS.
THE LEGALIZATION OF WORK,, THEY
ARE FOR THAT TOO APPEAR AT THE
DESTRUCTION OF THE FAMILY,
AND FARMLAND.
RACE BASED REPARATION
SPECIFICALLY "IN THE FORM OF A
GUARANTEED MINIMUM LIVABLE
INCOME FOR ALL BLACK PEOPLE."
DO YOU HEAR THAT?
ALL BLACK PEOPLE ARE NOT JUST
DESCENDANTS OF AMERICAN.
THIS WOULD INCLUDE MILLIONS OF
IMMIGRANTS WHO ON AVERAGE NOW
EARN MORE THAN NATIVE BORN
AMERICAN.
EVERYONE OF THESE NEW AMERICANS
WILL RECEIVE A GUARANTEED ANNUAL
INCOME FROM AMERICAN TAXPAYERS
IN A TONE FOR THE SCENT OF, FOR
THE SCENT OF WHAT, ACTUALLY?
ALLOWING THEM TO IMMIGRATE HERE?
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" DOES NOT
EXPLAIN THAT PART.
NOBODY ASKED THEM.
YOU CAN BE FIRED FOR ASKING.
WHAT YOU CANNOT BE PUNISHED FOR
HOWEVER LOOTING AND BURNING AT
LEAST IF YOU ARE
"BLACK LIVES MATTER."
HUGE PARTS OF THE URBAN
LANDSCAPE HAVE BEEN DESTROYED
AND NO ONE HELD TO ACCOUNT FOR
IT.
JUST THE OPPOSITE.
YOU ARE ENCOURAGED TO PRETEND IT
NEVER HAPPENED.
IN ST. LOUIS, EVERY RIDER
ARRESTED RELEASED WITHOUT
CHARGE.
IN NEW YORK HUNDREDS RELEASED
WITHOUT BAIL EMPHYSEMA IN
WASHINGTON, D.C.
IT’S HAPPENING EVERYWHERE AND
NOT IN PLACE IS JUST ELECTED BY
DEMOCRATS WHICH TELLS YOU A LOT.
FOR TAXES, EXAMPLE ONE OF THE
MAJOR AMERICAN CITIES WITH BETSY
PRICE.
THE DEMONSTRATORS PLUCKED A
BRIDGE IN DOWNTOWN FORT WORTH.
WHEN THE POLICE ARRIVE TO
DISPERSE THEM, THEY THREW ROCKS
AND BOTTLES OF BLEACH.
THREE POLICE OFFICERS INJURED.
THE MOB WENT ON TO LOOT AND
PENALIZE BUSINESSES, DOZENS OF
RIOTERS WERE ARRESTED FOR THIS.
TEN DAYS LATER THE POLICE CHIEF
ED KRAUSE ANNOUNCING HE WAS
DROPPING ALL CHARGES AGAINST --
HE ISSUED A STATEMENT SAYING THE
REAL CRIMINALS IN THE RIOT ARE
NOT THE RIOTERS BUT HIS OWN
POLICE OFFICERS WHOM HE
SUGGESTED WOULD BE REINED IN AND
PERHAPS PUNISHED.
"THIS IS JUST ONE STEP ON A LONG
JOURNEY, HE WROTE, SOUNDING MORE
LIKE A THERAPIST THAN A COP."
HIS WAS COMMITTED TO WALKING THE
PATH OF REFORM WITH THE
COMMUNITY.
THE PRESS NEVER BOTHERED TO
EXPLAIN WHAT HIS PUPS HAD DONE
WRONG.
THEY WERE COPS AND THAT WAS
ENOUGH.
THAT SAME DAY, THE SCHOOL BOARD
ISSUED A STATEMENT DECLARING
"POLICE PRACTICES ARE DEEPLY
ROOTED IN WHITE SUPREMACY."
NO ONE SAID WHICH THESE
PRACTICES WITH WHITE SUPREMACY
OR WITH THE ACCUSATION MEANT.
IT WAS A BLANKET CONDEMNATION
BUT IT WAS LEFT TO HANG IN THE
AIR.
AS USUAL, KNOW NOBODY IN
AUTHORITY PUSHED BACK IN A
REPUBLICAN-LED CITY.
IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO NOTE
WHAT HAPPENS TO THE MURDER RATE
IN FORT WORTH OVER THE NEXT
YEAR.
WE CAN GUESS.
WE SEE IT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY
AND WE HAVE SEEN IT MANY TIMES
THROUGH THE YEAR.
WHEN THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE
UNDERMINED THE LAW, VIOLENCE
SURGES.
BUT THERE IS A SOLUTION TO THIS
VORTEX AND IT’S CALLED
LEADERSHIP.
65 YEARS AGO POLITICIANS
THROUGHOUT THE AMERICAN SOUTH
BROWN VERSUS BOARD DECISION THE
AUTHORITIES SIMPLY IGNORE THE
LAW LIKE IT DIDN’T EXIST.
AND FILLED THE VACUUM, AND USE
VIOLENCE TO MAKE THEIR OWN LAW.
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
STEPPED IN TO RESTORE ORDER.
1957 PRESIDENT DWIGHT EISENHOWER
FEDERALIZED AND -- LITTLE ROCK
TO FORCED TO OBEY THE LAW.
SO THE QUESTION IS, WHERE IS OUR
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT TODAY?
RIGHT NOW?
IS THERE A REASON THE DOJ HASN’T
FILED FEDERAL CONSPIRACY CHARGES
AGAINST THE PEOPLE WHO ORGANIZE
AND LEAD THESE RIOTS?
AS LONG AS WE DON’T KNOW WHO
THEY ARE, THEIR CRIMES ARE ON
YOUTUBE.
YOU KNOW THE REASON,
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" WAS
INVOLVED.
IT IS POLITICALLY SENSITIVE.
NO ONE WANTS TO BE CALLED A
RACIST IS IF IT’S RACIST TO
PUNISH PEOPLE FOR CRIMES THEY
THEY COMMIT.
YOU ARE THE VICTIMS OF THOSE
CRIMES.
THE OLD PEOPLE BEATEN TO THE
GROUND FOR TRYING TO DEFEND
THEIR PROPERTY, THE SHOP OWNERS
WHOSE LIFE SAVINGS WERE STOLEN
OR BURNED.
THE FAMILIES OF THE PEOPLE
MURDERED DURING THE RIOTS AND
THERE WERE QUITE A FEW OF THEM.
NO ONE IS DEFENDING THESE
PEOPLE.
NO ONE IS PUNISHING THEIR
ATTACKERS.
NOBODY CARES.
IMAGINE HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT
THAT.
WHAT RECOURSE DO THEY HAVE?
DO THEY HAVE TO TORTURE WHEN
THESE?
LET’S HOPE NOT.
YOU MIGHT BE ENOUGH TO HAVE A
SINGLE NATIONAL LEADER, JUST ONE
WHO UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS ACTUALLY
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY AND IS
THAT MIGHT MAKE ALL THE
DIFFERENCE AND IT WOULD
CERTAINLY MAKE A POLITICAL
CAREER OF THE PERSON WHO
DOESN’T.
IN THE FALL OF 1968 FROM A
TEACHING ASSISTANT AT
SAN FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY
GEORGE MURRAY GAVE A SPEECH WITH
RACIAL VIOLENCE.
HE URGED BLACK STUDENTS TO BRING
GUNS TO CAMPUS AND "KILL ALL THE
MASTERS."
MURRAY BY THE WAY WAS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE EDUCATION IN THE
BLACK PANTHER PARTY WHICH WAS AN
PEOPLE AT THE TIME.
THEY EQUIVOCATED BUT ULTIMATELY
THEY SUSPENDED HIM UNDER
PRESSURE.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS A GROUP
CALLED THIRD WORLD LIBERATION
SHUT DOWN THE CAMPUS, SOUND
FAMILIAR?
THEY DEMAND AT THE UNIVERSITY
DROP ALL ADMISSION STANDARDS FOR
BLACK APPLICANTS AND ADMIT
PURELY ON THE BASIS OF RACE.
ADMINISTRATORS WERE PARALYZED IN
THE FACE OF THIS.
MORE THAN ANYTHING THEY DIDN’T
WANT TO BE CALLED RACIST.
THE PRESIDENT WAS SO TERRORIZED
BY IT THAT HE QUIT AND LEFT.
ULTIMATELY THE LEADERSHIP AT
SAN FRANCISCO STATE FAILED TO
UNLIKELY PRECEDENT.
FYI -- HE WAS SHORT, ECCENTRIC,
WORE THICK GLASSES BUT
COMPLETELY FEARLESS.
ON DECEMBER 2ND, 1968, HE
MARCHED IN THE MIDDLE OF A
STUDENT PROTEST.
WRITERS IMMEDIATELY ASSAULTED
HIM.
BUT HE KEPT GOING.
HE CLIMBED ONTO THE ROOF OF A
SOUNDTRACK AND RIPPED THE WIRE
SET UP A LOUDSPEAKER.
AND THE UNIVERSITY REOPENED THAT
DAY.
HERE IS A LESSON FOR TODAY’S
OFFICEHOLDERS.
HE BECAME A FOLK HERO FOR
STANDING UP TO THE MOB.
HE WAS ELECTED TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE FROM
CALIFORNIA.
THE REPUBLICANS SUPPORTED HIM.
VOTERS DID TOO.
THEY DIDN’T ALWAYS UNDERSTAND
HIM.
HE WORE A SCOTTISH CAP AND
REPUBLICAN NEVER EXPLAINED WHY
HE DID, BUT IT DIDN’T MATTER.
HE WAS BRAVE AND HONEST AND
VOTERS APPRECIATED THAT ABOVE
ALL.
THEY ALWAYS DO.
WE DON’T HAVE OUR GUY YET, BUT
COWARDS.
OUR LEADERS ARE HAPPY TO TALK
ABOUT EVERYTHING BUT THE
COLLAPSE OF CIVILIZATION
TUMBLING DOWN AROUND THEM.
THEY HAVE NO IDEA HOW HOW LITTLE
CREDIBILITY THEY HAVE OR
RELEVANT THEY HAVE BECOME.
IF YOU CAN’T TELL THE TRUTH WHEN
THE TRUTH ACTUALLY MATTERS, THEN
NOTHING YOU SAY MATTERS.
MEANWHILE, "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
BECOMES MORE POWERFUL AND MORE
POPULAR WITH THE PUBLIC.
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
EXACTLY, HERE’S WAY,
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" IS GETTING
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANT.
THAT IS THE MOST BASIC SIGN OF
STRENGTH, STRENGTH IS THE MOST
APPEALING QUALITY TO VOTERS AND
TO PEOPLE AND TO ANIMALS.
THREE WEEKS AGO,
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" DEMAND AT
THE CITY’S DEEP ON THEIR THE
MIGHTY NYPD THE BIGGEST POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND OUR NATION THE
MOST SOPHISTICATED DEPARTMENT
AND THE WORLD IS ABOLISHING ITS
ENTIRE DIVISION, PLAIN CLOTHED
DIVISION.
BECAUSE "BLACK LIVES MATTER"
WANTED IT AND IT IS DONE.
THAT IS NOT BLUFFING, POSTURING,
THAT IS NOT TWEETING, THAT IS
REAL POWER.
YOU NOTICED IT WILL NOT REQUIRE
THE USUAL MANEUVERING FOR
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" TO GET THE
POWER.
THEY DIDN’T NEED A TEAM OF
LAWYERS TO GET IT.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" DOESN’T
MAKE LEGAL ARGUMENTS.
THEY WILL NOT TRY TO CONVINCE
HER OF ANYTHING.
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" BELIEVES IN
FORCE.
THEY FLED THE STREETS WITH
ANGRY, YOUNG PEOPLE WHO BREAK
THINGS AND THEY HURT ANYONE WHO
GETS IN THE WAY.
WHEN THEY WANT SOMETHING, THEY
TAKE IT.
MAKE THEM MAD AND THEY WILL SET
YOUR BUSINESS ON FIRE.
ANNOY THEM AND THEY WILL OCCUPY
YOUR DOWNTOWN AND DECLARE A
BRAND-NEW COUNTRY.
YOU WILL NOT DO ANYTHING ABOUT
IT.
THEY KNOW THAT FOR CERTAIN.
THIS IS THE MOST OBSTRUCTIVE
KIND OF POLITICS.
WE SAW IT IN RECENT YEARS AND
THEY DID IT TO BRETT KAVANAUGH,
THE MAIN POINT OF SLANDERING HIM
WAS NEVER TO BLOCK HIS
CONFIRMATION.
YOU MISREAD THAT.
YOU KNEW THEY COULD NOT ACHIEVE
IT.
THE REAL POINT WAS TO SEND
BRETT KAVANAUGH AND JOHN ROBERTS
AND THE OTHER REPUBLICAN JUSTICE
IS A CLEAR MESSAGE, STEP OUT OF
LINE AND WE WILL HURT YOUR
FAMILIES.
JUDGING FROM RECENT COURT
DECISIONS, IT WORKED.
AT TIMES IT IS CLEAR SUPPOSEDLY
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES ARE AFRAID
TO DEFY THE MOB.
WHAT MESSAGE DO THE REST OF US
TAKE FROM WHAT HAS HAPPENED OVER
THE PAST FEW WEEKS?
IT IS VERY SIMPLE.
THE MESSAGES FORCE IS MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN VOTING.
ELECTIONS CHANGE NOTHING.
RIOTING BY CONTRAST MAKES YOU
RICH AND POWERFUL.
WHEN YOU RIOTS, PROSECUTORS WILL
IGNORE THE LAW ON YOUR BEHALF.
PREPARATIONS WILL SEND YOU
MILLIONS.
POLITICIANS WILL KNEEL DOWN
BEFORE YOU.
IT WORKS, VIOLENCE WORKS.
THAT IS THE MESSAGE.
EVERYONE HERE IS THAT MESSAGE
UNTIL VIOLENCE STOPS WORKING,
VIOLENCE WILL CONTINUE.
HOW POWERFUL IS BLACK LIVES
MATTER?
THE LEFT KEEPING THE PROTEST
GOING IS MORE IMPORTANT THAN
FIGHTING A DEADLY PANDEMIC.
IN THE CITY OF NEW YORK
OFFICIALS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO ASK